[Music]
you're indeed brave tonight but the
fight is mine oh and enough eh
look you stupid bastard you've got no
arms left yes i have look it's just a
flesh wound
hey there i'm frequent banana peel
slipper mark ellis and welcome back to
rt essentials before we get into today's
episode we've got to put on our thinking
cap all right what's the difference
between a parody and a spoof well
parodies generally have a bit more love
for the artists or work that it's
imitating and thus they stick closer to
the narrative structure of what's being
imitated a spoof much like the word
sounds is extra silly a spoof gets to
make genres and references regardless of
whether they might go together this
vitamix of humor is put on the maximum
setting to serve up a gag smoothie so if
you're expecting classics such as young
frankenstein and wet hot american summer
on this list guess what those are more
like loving parodies not mean old spoof
movies so without further ado here are
our picks for the best movie spoofs of
all time
monzy python and the holy grail what a
strange person now look here my good man
i don't want to talk to you no more you
empty-headed animal food trough whopper
i fart in your general direction your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelled of elderberries
is there someone else up there we can
talk to no now go away or i shall taunt
you a second time television was a
pretty bright and cheery place until the
british comedy troupe of monty python
released their mockery on polite society
into the world in 1975 the troop applied
their irreverence to king arthur and the
knights of the round table with monty
python and the holy grail drawing from
various knights quest tales to provide
the loosest of plot structures while
mixing in animation mockumentary and
even a few hilarious duels to boot on rt
essentials we often get deep into plot
synopsis but as you'll hear throughout
this list a spoof mostly has zero plot
and is more about providing space for
gags monty python of the holy grail
starts with king arthur's recruitment
for the knights of the round table
including sir not appearing in this film
but by a snap of the finger god scuttles
that by sending them all on a quest to
find the holy grail and while the plot
does concern a quest what we all
remember and love about the holy grail
are the ludicrously long discussions of
sparrows and carrying coconuts and how
to determine if someone is in fact a
witch or a duck did you dress her up
like this
no no no no no no yes yes yes yeah a
[ __ ]
she has got a wart
what makes you think she is a witch well
she turned me into a newt
a newt
while mighty python is poking fun at all
the legends they're also spoofing stuffy
cinema at large not allowing a single
second let alone the opening credits to
go by with any seriousness whatsoever at
the very start of the film plain and
stately film critics get hijacked by
subtitlers looking for their
scandinavian moose those subtitlers are
sacked their replacements are sacked and
eventually more than 40 llamas receive
credit above the film's directors though
holy grail keys in on one genre it
doesn't mimic the stateliness and after
giving us something completely different
monty python changed comedy forever as
an obvious influence on modern comedy
mainstays like saturday night live and
the simpsons
airplane flight two zero niner you are
cleared for takeoff roger huh la
departure frequency one two three point
niner roger all right request vector
over what flight two zero niner clear
for vector three four we have clearance
clearance roger roger what's our vector
victor
our radio clearance
the writer director team of jim abrahams
and brothers david and jerry zucker or
zucker abrahams and zucker or z-a-z zazz
created the template that most of us
think of when someone says spoof a
conveyor belt of jokes which ultimately
just make fun of anything popular these
movies use the confines of a specific
genre that's been cranked out by
hollywood at the time as the backdrop
for non-stop gaggery it also includes
movies outside of the genre that's
getting some ribbing as well for
instance airplane released in 1980 used
the familiarity we have with disaster
franchises like airport and earthquake
to toss in gags involving movies that
have nothing to do with the genre it
mocked like saturday night fever and
from here to eternity like disaster
movies what little character arc exists
in airplane is attached to a romantic
couple julie haggerty is a stewardess
who's just broken up with her boyfriend
played by robert hayes who is afraid of
flying due to his war days the former
pilot follows her onto a flight and once
all the pilots get sick he is tasked
with landing safely for the passengers
and crew
the stewardess said
both pilots
can you fly this plane and land it
surely you can't be serious
i am serious and don't call me shirley
doctor i've checked everyone mr
striker's the only one
what flying experience have you had in
addition to the lowbrow thrillers of the
70s that it mocks airplane uses our own
familiarity with flying as a comedy
target which if you've been on a plane
at all ever you could probably relate to
parking zone misunderstandings overly
talkative passengers and bad airplane
food
and i think it's even gotten worse since
1980. you're going to be so jealous of
the legroom that exists in every row on
this particular airplane zazz team
direct their cast to play it straight
and they stuff the overhead bins with
various naughty jokes and dump it all
out in one big panicked jostle of
turbulence alright fasten your seat
belts and before we move on to the next
film note the warning signs for landing
the rest of this video and might i steer
you away from the fish
walk hard the dewey [ __ ] story stop that
stop your singing
stop your singing this instant young man
i will not have this in my studio
uh maybe it was the wrong song choice if
you just let me play one of my songs
that i wrote i think you'll like it a
whole lot better you have failed
conclusively
it's over
and there is nothing that you can do
here in this room
that can turn that around
nothing you can do that can make up for
what you just did to that samore well my
mother liked it a whole lot your mother
was wrong in 2007 walk hard the dewey
[ __ ] story followed a handful of
musician biopics that recently won top
acting oscars rey and walk the line and
turn their similar cradle to grave
constructions into a cult classic spoof
john c rowley's first leading role is a
fictional country music heartthrob named
dewey cox who he plays from age 14 to
age 71. dewey's journey starts with a
tragic childhood accident stumbles into
the country music big time invents punk
rock and lives through many downward
spirals prompted by his bandmate tim
meadows get out of here dewey what are
you all doing in here we're smoking
reefer
and you don't want no part of this
you're smoking reefers yeah of course we
can't you smell it
no sam
i can't
come on dewey join the party no dewey
you don't want this get out of here
you know what i don't want no hangover i
can't get no hangover it doesn't give
you a hangover
well
i'll get addicted to it or something
it's not habit-forming
this spoof followed the very recent
back-to-back oscar wins of ray and
walked the line and it hit every right
note in the behind the music genre
although it's one of co-writer and
producer judd apatow's biggest box
office bomb it amassed a fervent cult
following of which i'm a member thereby
completing its own metabiopic cycle of
being more appreciated after the
original release as jason shine of the
nashville scene declared in 2020 it's
safe to call this a modern classic by
now
spaceballs prepare to die
you have the ring
and i see your schwartz is as big as
mine
now let's see how well you handle it
released in 1987 mel brooks space balls
not only mocked the highest grossing
movies of the era the star wars flicks
it pretty much made fun of all popular
sci-fi beyond the galaxy far far away
other sci-fi franchises like alien 2001
a space odyssey star trek and planet of
the apes get poked nothing otherworldly
popular is safe from mockery and
spaceballs even the wizard of oz brooks
takes aim not just at the space sagas
but also merchandising around movie
franchises and box office obsessions
that turn movies into money measuring
contests but there's still plenty of
love to go around i mean brooks even got
john hurt to recreate his alien chest
bursting scene for a show tunes gag
careful you idiot i said across her nose
not up it
sorry sir i'm doing my best
who made that man a gunner i did sir
he's my cousin
who is he he's an ulcer
i know that what's his name that is his
name sir
major
and his cousin he's a loser gunners made
first class phillip
how many we got on this ship anyhow
i knew it i'm surrounded by
mel brooks is an icon within the parody
genre but because young frankenstein
recreates so many of the classic scenes
in frankenstein and with such reverence
it's spaceballs that best typifies his
later career spoof output from the
disgusting kind of delicious pizza of
the hut to giant space helmets to yogurt
the wise spaceballs is brooks mocking
the era of filmmaking he's in instead of
making an ode to the hollywood of yore
though his old hollywood parodies are
held in higher regard critics say
there's fine spoofery and amusing
characters in spaceballs and currently
it's at 59
on the tomato meter which is oh so close
to fresh
austin powers international man of
mystery here's the plan
we get the warhead and we hold the world
ransom for
one million dollars
[Music]
well don't you think we should maybe ask
for more than a million dollars a
million dollars isn't exactly a lot of
money these days
virtucon alone makes over nine billion
dollars a year really
of course spoof movies come naturally to
saturday night live actors who would
regularly parody popular films and
television within their era more on
their skit adaptations in a minute but
it's snl alum mike myers who gets to
shout out here for his original spoof
franchise austin powers austin powers
drops an international spy from the 60s
into the 90s where the mood is
quite different paris was frozen in the
60s to be awoken when his arch nemesis
dr evil returned to earth and while
paris is positioned primarily as a james
bond spoof it's the frozen in time
aspect that let myers jump around
popular genres in each austin powers
adventure the introductory scenes mimic
the swing in london era of the beatles a
hard day's night and even the
international art house favorite of blow
up
you know i have one simple request
and that is to have sharks with freaking
laser beams attached to their heads now
evidently my cycloptic colleague informs
me that that can't be done
can you remind me what i pay you people
for honestly throw me a bone here myers
doesn't look or sound like a 60s playboy
like 007 the beatles or renowned
fashionista which creates a space for
loads of gags throughout the trilogy of
austin powers the time that passed
between the 60s and 90s would allow for
multiple star wars buffoonery some lines
from jerry maguire and the exorcist in
addition to the more absurd leaps taken
in james bond's adventures by the time
of gold mother things got even more meta
where mike myers lifted a line from his
voice work and shrek you're going the
right way for a smack bottom and applied
it to the bedroom oh behave
macgruber hey now before we do this any
questions why do i have to be hoss
because you're good at what you do and
why do i have to be you first of all you
will never be me and second of all
i forget your question okay
so it looks like we're dealing with
three guards here
it's three on three okay so once we take
out the guards vicky will walk in
dressed as hoss and then we'll just
you know see what happens you ready
while many snl sketch characters got
their own movies like the blues brothers
and the coneheads will forte's mcgruber
is the rare instance of an snl spoof
getting a feature film magruber first
appeared as a sketch in 2007 the credit
jingle and thrust of the presentation
was mocking the tv series macgyver where
the quick thinking agent always was able
to coolly defuse a bomb with random
everyday objects seconds before
explosion in forte's snl sketch his
personality problems with people he's
attempting to rescue caused the bomb to
go off because he knows how to defuse a
bomb but he has no internal clock and he
also has very low interpersonal
interaction skills the sketch was turned
into a pepsi commercial and then finally
we got a movie 2010's mcgruber was
directed by jormuth the cone of the
comedy trio lonely island and because
it's a full-length movie forte and jacob
were able to pull into the common action
movie trope of one last mission
i would love to
but the van's pretty full
you see it's filled with american heroes
with over 100 years of combined combat
experience and a whole lot of
brotherhood and no you can't ride in the
trunk bud
because the trunk is filled with over 75
pounds of homemade c4 explosive that i
personally packed in there with my own
two
at the start of mcgruber forte plays a
former special operative who is called
back into action to take down his arch
enemy dieter von koth played by val
kilmer aided by snl alum kristen wiig as
vicky st elmo mcgruber not only has more
explosions than snl could afford but
also has more raunchy scenes than could
ever air on network tv even at 11 30 pm
that too hot for tv approach made
critics say it too often mistakes shock
value for real humor but magruber is
better than most snl films mcgruber was
a box office bomb that's grown to have a
large enough cult following to spawn its
own series and upcoming sequel streaming
on peacock
hollywood shuffle
they've murdered your only loving
daughter
[Music]
[Music]
my dog
let's pause here to dive into a
different type of spook we've already
established that hollywood can make fun
of itself but how about when it does it
with fake movies within a broader comedy
kind of like picture in picture except
it's spoof within satire most of these
movies are made by deeply entrenched
talent like ben stiller's tropic thunder
so let's go a little earlier to a
hollywood satire made by a struggling
actor robert townsend who held nothing
back in hollywood shuffle rife with
uncomfortable spoofs and truth i would
shuffle pulls from townsend's own
experience of auditioning for roles in a
post eddie murphy hollywood where all
the studios wanted was an eddie murphy
type in real life townsend had
auditioned for saturday night live the
same year as murphy and was not in the
cast as an actor he was discouraged by
the type of typecasting roles he was
being offered by 1987 townsend co-wrote
directed and starred in hollywood
shuffle which follows the exploits of an
up-and-coming actor but pauses
throughout the film to skewer the
featured roles that hollywood had
offered black actors the film uses a
stereotypical audition to segue to an
instructional video for black movie
acting where white instructors show
black actors how to act out hollywood
stereotypes correctly for the bulk of
the roles being offered at that time
learn chive top 101 you [ __ ]
jazz turkey [ __ ]
all right that's good that's good you
work all right you try it
you you [ __ ] mothers
no no no no no no that's wrong that's
wrong watch me man just be cool
jeff tricky [ __ ]
[Applause]
that's only the beginning the comedy
even pauses at one point to mimic a
siskel and ebert at the movies episode
where black movie reviewers speed and
tyrone review made up versions of
amadeus indiana jones and dirty harry
for sneaking in the movies townsend also
uses hollywood shuffle to dream up the
roles he'd like to play with versions of
shakespeare a made-up superhero and his
own take on rambo named ram bro this is
all on the way to imagining his fifth
oscar win completing that quest for gold
requirement of hollywood spoofs
townsend's endless ribbing of the
industry and what it had to offer black
creatives was a pioneering comedy which
was also the writing debut of keenan
ivory wayans wayans would go on to
direct his own blaxploitation spoof the
following year i'm gonna get you sucka
the first step towards cementing the
wayans family in the spoof genre so
that's a handy segue to our very next
movie
scary
wind
movie
yeah
where am i
um
you're you're behind the couch
what how do you know that i can um see
your feet
okay turn around close your eyes no
peeking
scary movie was co-written by sean and
marlon wayans and directed by keenan
ivory williams scary movie would become
a spoof franchise like most of the
horror movies that it mocked the
franchise actually lasted so long that
it changed alongside horror tropes going
from teen slashers like scream and i
know you did last summer to the torture
movie cycle that started with saw anna
ferris and regina hall starred in all
four of the scary movies but it was
carmen elektra who recreated the drew
barrymore scream opening which much like
the movie at mox is one of the best
openings to a movie spoof
[Music]
horror movies are a natural spoof target
because not only are they popular but
they're cheap to make meaning that
mocking them is going to be even less
expensive the parody of a popular scary
film is actually almost as old as
hollywood itself with laurel and hardy
doing comedy monster movie spin-offs in
the 40s and 50s there's also student
bodies in the 80s which even spells out
how many slashers were made the previous
year and how much money they made but
scary movie went beyond horror movies
and just took a stab at anything in the
zeitgeist from eight mile to the matrix
and charlie's angels
this is spinal tap this is a top to uh
you know what we use on stage but it's
very very special because if you can see
yeah the numbers all go to
11. look right across the board
11 11 and
does that mean it's louder is it any
louder well it's one louder isn't it
next we go to a spoof that popularized a
whole different movie format the
mockumentary this is final tap was
released in 1984 after glam metal had
taken over pop culture with its own
breed of ridiculousness for his
directorial debut rob reiner used
successful 1970s rock documentaries like
led zeppelin's the song remains the same
as the framework for this music industry
spoof tap utilized the cast of then
mostly unknowns who were actually
competent musicians and thus could sell
the metal performances first doju-san
authorized personnel only yeah open
their door that's the stage you think so
you authorize your musicians yeah all
right thank you thank you very much rock
and roll
[Applause]
no no this way this way
the principal cast of christopher guest
michael mckeon harry shearer and rob
reiner also all co-wrote the film beyond
being one of the most quotable movies of
all time this is spinal tap showed why
the mockumentary format would be a
comedic boom capturing cringe-worthy
moments that feel authentic because of
the interview format for this is spinal
tap reiner plays filmmaker marty
debergie who's tasked with following the
british rock and roll group's final tap
on their 1982 us tour in support of
their new album smell the glove critics
say smartly directed brilliantly acted
and packed with endlessly quotable
moments this is final tap is an all-time
comedy classic
top secret
i'm not the first guy who fell in love
with the girl he met in a restaurant who
then turned out to be the daughter of a
kidnapped scientist only the loser to a
childhood lover who she'd last seen on a
deserted island and who turned out 15
years later to be the leader of the
french underground
i know it
it all sounds like some bad movie
let's come full circle and end the back
half of this list with a cult favorite
zazz film top secret top secret was the
film debut of val kilmer who stars as a
crooning rock star nick rivers after a
hip shaking performance rivers get swept
up in international intrigue in an
unfolding war plot part of the reason
top secret is so beloved by spoof fiends
is because it pulls from a whole pantry
of movies and genres instead of sticking
to an actual recipe from elvis presley
movies to cold war thrillers 1960s beach
comedies world war ii movies and more
recently successful flicks like the blue
lagoon there wasn't a time period or
genre to hold on to for structure so you
just had to go to where the jokes were
taking the audience and while that
incoherence was caused for box office
failure it was perfect for video store
or cable tv discovery that's the way i
found it
[Music]
so
[Music]
critics say top secret finds the team of
the zuckers and abrams sending up
everything from spy movies to elvis
musicals with reckless loony abandon and
hey the king of song parodies himself
weird al yankovic calls it his all-time
favorite movie telling the av club that
he actually told that to val kilmer on
get this an airplane you get it because
the zazz folks also made airplane and
now weird alan valor talking top secret
on a moving airplane and it just wraps
this episode up nicely for everyone
including me who does consider top
secret to possibly be the funniest movie
ever and there you have it our list of
the greatest spoof movies ever made we
hope you learned a little something
about the difference between a spoof and
a parody and can use it at your next
water cooler talk to sound smart or
alienate yourself at a dinner party i'm
mark ellis and as always stay tuned for
more rt essentials thanks for watching
and now maybe i think holy grail might
be my favorite funny movie of all time
but top secrets right there y'all go
watch him and tell us what you think
[Music]
[Music]
you